Susan pages USA TODAY's Washington
bureau chief welcome thank you so
looking at the defeat on health care
what does it mean for the presence
agenda specifically tax reform and
infrastructure you know it's damaging
its damaging for one part because he is
weakened politically by demonstrating
that he couldn't deliver on this
fundamental promise it also raises
questions about the White House
operation on their ability to build a
coalition with Congress on an issue like
tax reform you know that we heard the
Treasury Secretary Steven Newton saying
it would be simpler than health care
that's simply history says that's simply
not true they have to skip go ahead
that's the tax reform maybe the toughest
issue of all and they have to scale down
the emissions yes because under the
budget rules if they do it by Budget
Reconciliation so that they can do it
with just a majority in the Senate it
means it has to be revenue neutral over
ten years and because they failed on
health care they didn't get that one
trillion dollars in tax cuts that they'd
hope to get to contribute to to the
bottom line there well we've heard
whines freebets say that now maybe they
will reach out to moderate Democrats is
their incentive for Democrats to work
with this white house now it's hard to
imagine why a Democrat at this moment
would want to send a lifeline to the
president into the Republicans who are
in such peril at this moment now the one
reason might be actually help the health
care system get better yeah and that
might be a powerful incentive but
there's a big political incentive here
to wait until the next midterm election
which is in in that in just next year to
see if Democrats can score big gains
even win control of the Congress that'll
be a stretch and then deal with the
president from a position of real Susan
it reminds me of marital counseling
where the counselor said to me do you
want to be right or do you want peace at
some point the two sides have to say one
has to be the bigger person say we're
going to work together you know say yes
I want both it doesn't work that way as
you know and you know what if you ask
politicians in Washington right now
they'd say we'd want to be right well
and that puts us on track for something
like your government shutdown which you
just heard chip Reid say as possible at
the end of April that's right we've got
to have a spending bill pass by the end
of april or the government will shut
down this is one of those difficult
unglamorous things to happen it doesn't
have the big glory payoff of repealing
the Affordable Care Act it's something
Republicans historically don't really
like to do but they are in charge of the
government
and so they are in the hook to do that
does this force president Trump to
become more engaged mean the criticism
has been he's not a details guy does he
need to become one now you know one of
the things we're going to be watching is
one of the lessons learned what lessons
do does president Trump learn from these
early experiences the Affordable Care
Act and others in these first 67 days of
his presidency and does he make
adjustments we saw you know for instance
President Clinton had a rocky start back
ta de rocky eight years but he still got
things done because he was constantly
applying lessons learned from the last
defeat will president Trump be like that
we don't know is he learning that there
are differences between being the
president being the candidate you know
some of the things that were that
enabled him to win the election are
making it harder for him to govern you
know for instance he wasn't a
standard-issue Republican that was a
good thing as a candidate but it means
that he has a different agenda in some
ways from paul ryan paul ryan is a
conservative Republican wants a smaller
government on this health care to be
President Trump wanted to make sure he
protected some of the voters he drew to
the Republican side this time resident
Trump also was a very big picture guy
you remember as a candidate sometimes as
president you really need to get down in
the week what happened to Planned
Parenthood well you know that's a that's
a big issue Planned Parenthood at the
moment still funded Obamacare is still
the law Glen after Republicans promise
for seven and a half years to repeal it
they're in power they weren't able to do
it thank you thank you for always good
to have you here